hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the chest bull masters 2020
this is the last game will be showing
and it is Game four of the rapids
so Magnus won the game one of their of
their second match and well the second
and third game ended in a draw and now
this is game for Giri must win it to
force the double it's playoffs and
hopefully to win the second match so the
so he can force a third match so it's
it's quite a game and again a very long
theoretical struggle so let's just dive
straight into it Giri opens with d4 and
we have Knight to f6 by Magnus we have
c4 e6 Knight of 3 and B 5 we go into the
Queens gambit declined we have Knight to
c3 and now c6 going for for the semi
slob defense with Bishop to g5 and
Knight B to d7
we have III now preparing to develop the
light square bishop and now going for
the Canberra Springs variation with
Queen to a5 preparing the Catherine c4
while opening up a discovery here on the
bishop here so nice the b2 now this
knife can move so it's not a problem and
the characters on c4 this is all very
standard now there's an attack on the
bishop so you have to wait before you
recapture the pawn
so first Bishop captures we have Knight
captures and only now Knight captures
and c4 Bishop captures and c4 is also
played here but not a nun nearly assault
in his night-gown first Knight
characters is the main main line we have
Queen back to c7 and now rook the c1 so
nothing nothing new with Bishop to e7
preparing the castle and the g3 now
preparing to fianchetto the bishop and
Castle King side we have castles by
black and now Bishop Bishop to g2 now we
have worked a d8 by Magnus and now Gary
just castles with Bishop to d7 and here
efore now Gary really nicely controlled
the center here and Magnus needs to
figure out how to how to properly
develop his pieces and get his bishop
pair to be to be very active so here he
goes b5 her first kicks away the knight
from c4 Knights the e3 and now Queen to
b6 there is a game from 2013 that was
played between onigiri and Sunnah Bert
Hanson
we're Queen to a5 was played but here
Magnus goes for Queen to b6 it's hard to
save Magnus knows of this game but it
could very well be that he does and that
he decided to play a different line than
the one giri already played here so here
with E 5 challenging the knight Knight
to d5 and now Knight to e4 here we have
Bishop back to e 8 now just freeing up
the D file for the rook and the bishop
will also be a very useful defender here
if white decides to do something let's
say queen h5 stuff and then just the
tries and go for the black King and here
there is a game where night the c5 was
played however here Gary goes for a3
which is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine and it is as
of move 18 that we have a completely new
game and this is where where the fun
starts so here with a 5 Magnus continues
developing on the Queen side pushing
pawns to be more precise as there is no
there is no good way to start getting
those bishops to some are lovely the
animals and you will have some issues
getting rid of your backwards c6 pawns
since it's all it's always gonna be a
problem to execute c5 white really has a
nice grip grip on the c5 square so here
we have Queen to b3 just improving the
position of the Queen preparing to bring
the other rook into the game and rook a7
the rook can now be shifted over to the
C falter the default wherever it's it's
better suited and you also want to get
it away from this diagonal so Knight the
c5 blockade before before you attack and
it is just a nice square for the knight
if if you go for characters here then
you will just you know get your rook to
see if I bring the artwork to c1 and
then you will put a lot of pressure to
this backwards pawn so here we have a 4
instead I just continuing to expand and
now Bishop the e4 here Aguirre puts
pressure on the h7 point so magnus goes
h6 and now rook F to D 1 so again just
putting pieces on optimal squares and
here Magnus goes back with Queen to b8
we have Queen to e 2 now Gary wants to
shoot the Queen over to the Kia to the
King side to start an attack against
crossings king
gear is in a must-win situation if he
doesn't win this game it's game over for
him
I mean he he wins second place and
Magnus is the winner of the 2020
chasuble master so here Magnus goes b4
he wants to open up some lines for his
pieces we have Knight to g4 by Giri and
B captures on a3 we have B characters
and a3 by recapturing and now Bishop
captures on c5 Magnus decides to get rid
of the the excellently placed Knight
rook captures on c5 and now rook to b7
grabbing hold of the open B file
preparing some I worked a b2 action but
Giri finds a beauty here push her back
to C - and now something like Ruby -
will not be all that impressive because
the Queen easily unpin and now already
threatens Queen to h7 and you can't
really play g6 because then the h6 bone
is hanging and so on so here instead
Magnus goes back Knight to e7 if needed
you can block Queenie forward Knight to
g6 so you do not have to worry about any
h7 square weaknesses but here Giri goes
for it he goes Knight to f6 check and
it's quite a quite a beauty because if
the knight is captured for example G
captures it captures the knight is under
attack 9g 6 now it's very tricky Queen
e3 going after the pawn here and if you
defend it than just a rock h5 and it's
game over for black so that's not what
you do here what you do here is you play
Queen b6 so you can bring the Queen back
to f8 so you don't have to worry about
checkmate here however even then h4 is
coming and black really has no good
moves here
like if h5 rook just captures it the
pawn is still hanging if Queen f8 then
h6 just traps the night the night has
nowhere to go
you could go of course @ h8 but that's
not that's not very impressive the rook
and Queen the Bishop every everyone
working together will find their way at
to the black Kings I'm like let's say
rookie 5 to here to here and the black
king will be in big trouble as the
bishop is beautifully covering this
diagonal so after Knight to f6 check
with King to f8 by Magnus and now comes
Queen to g4
now again offering the night but you you
still you still don't capture this
because
well the ideas are pretty much the same
so here after rook to b5 Magnus just
continues he says I'm not touching that
night with Knight to h5 Giri now
threatens mate on g7 and now Crossan has
to defend with the g6 and now Queen to
f4 again giri wit with the fancy fancy
moves again offering a knight here
however if this Knight is captured then
Queen h6 check King to g8 and now you
just deliver a whole lot of checks Queen
h7 checking f8 first you trade on b5 and
only after captures Dani go queen h8
check tonight has to block and now you
recapture by Bishop to h7 you're winning
the the piece back and you will be much
better for example let's say Bishop c6
are gonna go Queen captures and g8 with
check and after the King moves it's well
it's almost equal material White is up a
pawn but also in a much much better
position so white white would be winning
here so instead after Queen to f4 Magnus
went Knight to f5 he defends the dh6
pawn and he's basically offering this
trade characters and then captures so
giri first goes for looked out for sun
b5 you want to get rid of any threats
Magnus has along the B file we have
Queen characters and b5 and now Bishop
captures here and now of course you
don't recapture and allow Queen captures
and h6 so first you kick away the Queen
and now he really has to figure out a
good square for the Queen and the good
square for the Queen is somewhere along
this diagonal for example Queen c1 and
then if Magnus recaptures then you bust
open the position with h4 that's that's
how you that's how you should do it and
this is a this would be very very nice
for white however give we went for Queen
to f3
he wants to be able to recapture here
once
Magnus captures on f5 so Magnus
recapture says piece and now now give
replay the Queen captures on f5 but that
is not the the precise way to do it you
have to go Knight f6 first and only then
will you capture here for example if
Queen b3 with a double attack you will
first block let's say rook d3 and after
Queen to be one check you're gonna move
the King and next you can infiltrate the
position any way you want and keep your
advantage however after this he captures
an f5 giri capture than f5 immediately
this allows Magnus a way out of the game
which he wouldn't have so I feel free to
pause the video here and try to save
this game for black while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the double attack and also
the move that stops the e6 move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show its Queen to e2 this is what give
me missed and now the rook is under
attack in the knight is under attack and
also you don't have East 6 because the
Queen just covers that square so it's
not a problem
so here something has to go Magnus
decided to give up the knight of course
you're not gonna give up the drug he
played rook to see one that's our
aguirre and now Magnus captured on h5
and now it's Magnus was up a piece he's
up a full bishop so Queen to have six
now with some Queen to h8 ideas but it's
it's not enough the rook is also under
attack so Magnus first moves it we have
rook captures on d4 and now Queen - a
cheat with Czech other than that you
don't really have anything you're down a
piece black black is just well without
going for Queen to h8 check black is
just better and there is no more way for
Gary to win this game so here I get
replayed the Queen - a trick check King
the e7 and now he forced a repetition we
have Queen to f6 with check Magnus just
went back King to f8 you don't want to
go somewhere like Kings to d7 because
then you allow Queen captures on c6 the
row covers that so Magnus just went back
and now Gary just kept repeating Queen
AJ checking e7 in Queen to f6 check
Magnus played King f8 and we do have a
draw by threefold repetition so Gary had
it he also I think he also had a winning
position in Game two over their second
match and also here in Game four but
it's rapid anything can happen and in
this game it did not happen so very
close for Gary but in the end the
magnets pulled through and he wins the
2020 chess simple masters with a with
the first price of I think $45,000 next
the next stop in the Magnus
a chest or I believe is the chest
Legends tournament we still don't know
who all the legends are that we'll be
playing but as soon as I know I will
inform everyone of course so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it ended this
very short coverage of the 2020 chasuble
masters I would like to thank start up
and go Francesca Woodcock Randolph Akuma
bonk you Yuri Gupta and the Martin
chillage for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the not 2020
chasuble masters but the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world and I also have some new
fun videos lined up for for maybe next
week so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day